This was a complete conspiracy, a fairy plane was
made, now there are many opinions inside it whether
IB did it or
I did it, now this thing is going on on social media
but it is known that this
was a fairy plane and they did it completely.
I had only one point to eliminate you in this manner, that those who are
trying to eliminate the viewpoint through oppression and stubbornness do
not even
know human nature, they do not know human history, they only know how to eat
human moments.  When
revolution came in Iran,
they committed great atrocities
on those people but could not stop it, no one from
our party can stop it and today I salute the
people that despite so much pressure,
our leadership is standing today.  Are you yours,
I swear on you, I am yours today, whoever
I will give PTI ticket to will
win Inshallah
and he will win only because people have taken a decision,
tell me if this has ever happened
in the history of Pakistan, the
establishment is associated with them,
Election Commission is associated with them.  There are
also other fees and other agencies associated with them,
along with this, this
category of government has never been
completely created and the
funds are giving everything to them, they
are running away from their mosquitoes.
That is, whenever
our establishment's liquor is
running away, it
ends when its vote bank ends, the
vote bank is over, you keep increasing the hunger in this horse as
much as you want,
when there are
more snakes in the race.  We can end ours
but the third thing I want to say is that someone is
wondering then
how come someone asked now will they call
electricity, they have asked
that the price of ₹ 100 which used to come to us when we
left it, is only ₹ 50.  The
buyer's price has gone up,
someone inside the gay has asked, how are the
weak people passing by,
I am talking about the salaried people, those who
get the typical salary, they have wondered
how they are passing and have thought that  At
present, our professionals
who can do any job in the world, do you have
any idea how big a loss it would be
if we had built Shaukat Khanum Cancer Hospital in Pakistan
and all of you now
go to the world Jain, if you get a cancer hospital there then
head out.  People from their staff
who have been canceled are
now thinking of leaving,
10% of Americans are leaving
and if I am talking about my institution
then I know what is happening in other places
when the professionals of this country.  People are
leaving their native places due to
fear of it
and secondly they are
sending dollars out. At this time there is
no shyness, no work is being done, people are buying dollars for
more than 300 rupees, what is going to happen in Pakistan,
no investment.
Someone inside Pakistan is feeling shy,
wants to do some work and is sitting holding the dollar, no take it
from the bed, no commercial bank
is ready to give the money
and all the record indicators of Pakistan that we had
left behind were record
exports, today the exports are falling.
IT was
75% of our exports. Congratulations, it was our future
technology.
How much money is the farmer making today
because the inflation will be so high that he
no longer has that much money in his hand?
As much money comes to the farmer, he will invest it on the land.  Have you
ever asked
that there is an action center due to which the wealth is distributed due to which
you have to repay the loan, which is the
industry, the industry is going bankrupt, today
unemployment is failing, recording
was industrial production, ours was 10 sari
lodge scale manufacturing, in our last
month today it has fallen.  The most
scary thing happening today is that when your dollars have been
working since the past, when your dollars have started coming in less,
what will happen to the remittances and exports,
fool, then he goes on loan again, it is going on, now we are
taking record loan, we have reached improvement.
Curzon is in trouble, our tax
money will go away,
so I am trying to understand
whether those who are deciding to
keep Imran Khan out,
a Pakistan
dubbed, are they not able to see that?  They do
n't even have a road map.
Today I am ready to form a committee. It's
a joking committee. At
this time, there are powerful people. I should go and talk to them.
If this committee is to sit and say yes,
Pakistan will be better off without Imran Khan.
And do you have any solution, I
say again that for the sake of this country I am
leaving, I am leaving behind, if
you make this committee understand that it will be better without me,
I am ready to leave even if the country remains intact
or else.
What is the benefit to Pakistan by holding elections in October?
I understand that the
dates will be taken care of by October, but
what is the benefit to Pakistan, why are we
waiting till October?  When the fools are going
down, I will make these two things.
Inshallah, I will do it easily tomorrow,
but today I will finally finish two things.
One, at the end, I want to talk about Al Qader.
In 4 hours, 4:30 hours, I will get a
new one.  I sat in the meeting tomorrow, I want to talk about it,
but before that, I appeal on behalf of my
Supreme Court. I
hope that
now the Rule of Doctor has ended in Pakistan and it
will almost end in this country.
14 I said that he gave the date to the Justice.  Sir
and Supreme Court
in 14 Gurjar did not make any difference to anyone,
so
what is the meaning of this,
now it means that the powerful one will decide
who is following them, he has
definitely started keeping an eye on them, who did
not save them and is the last hope.  Now
all those who are part of the Jamuria are being destroyed one by one
or there is no Jamuria,
now I am sitting, so which day will they come every day and
catch me? Have you
caught me or not, which Jhumaria?  I feel like giving
blessings to all the people. I do
n't know who should I contact or how to contact
me. I am not getting any quantity.
Leader
Shiv has banned the internet and ended Zoom,
so
I am doing whatever.  Whatever they come
to do, whenever they come to catch me, I am
sitting well, I get ready every day, it is
very important for
you.
[Music]
Sir, the judge of the Supreme Court
gives a big test to those people to whom he gives responsibility.  It is
up to you, it is up to us, our
decision was taken inside the cabinet on 3rd December
2019,
now you look at it as if you are my cabinet
member
and what decision did you make
wrong,
this decision had
started being made a year ago, you
decided and  And its ground was
decided, now this decision was taken, just
understand yourself that
this thing was placed in front of my cabinet member cabinet,
one of our Malik Riyaz and
NCA is a national crime,
his agency is a national crime.
190 million pounds inside England
and when he heard what is this
transaction, he
said, why should we doubt, this money is
not white money, it is black money, he froze the money, there is
an agreement between Malik Riaz and MCA.
Lawyers make an agreement and
the decision is taken under the agreement.
Malik Riaz says that this is the 190 million
pounds that I had
promised to the Supreme Court in Pakistan and the
fine that was imposed on me, I
want to deposit it in my account.
Now this comes before our cabinet of the Supreme Court
that you have two choices
if you will
keep this agreement confidential i.e.
you will not open it inside the cabinet because if they
open it then it will become public because it will be the
minutes of the cabinet
so we will keep it confidential.
But if someone wants to open a court then it
is open power
or some new agency wants to open it, it is
just an award, if you are not confident about it then
how will the government have to go inside Britain and find out that
this 190 million pounds is
money from Pakistan.  Laundering has taken place
and you will have to prove that
money has been laundered from Pakistan.
Now you understand how if you lose then this
money will go to England or your 190
million pounds will go to England.
So if you win then  If so, then he will
come to Pakistan and he will come in another person,
he will
not go to the account of the Supreme Court, the money will go to the
Government of Pakistan,
we have not received it till date through legal action and
they said that this litigation will continue for 5-6 years
and there is no guarantee.  It is not possible that you will be
able to prove that my money that was laundered has
gone to England. Now this was the
decision of the cabinet. What will you decide whether the
₹190 million pounds I am
getting should go to Pakistan. At this time
we needed huge wealth.  It is always there,
even today we need money and
this much money has never come to Pakistan. Should we
bring this money to Faridabad and
deposit it in State Bank or should we take legal action
which will last for 5-6 years and I
don't know.  The money will not come, please tell me one person
who will oppose it, bring that money to
Pakistan, that
money has been deposited in the report,
now 109 million pounds were
given next time because you Malik
Riaz has given the Al Qader Trust for you.  The
head of his life was Spencer,
today you have 190 million pounds lying with you, there is a
new argument in the Supreme Court that the money has been invested in the wrong thing,
how can you go inside England and
prove that the money is laundered and it is
there.  Will go there to
prove that the money launderer's money has gone and
how to do it. So
what is stopping you?
If you think that it has gone in the wrong direction,
then you
still have the opportunity, how only to
humiliate me and  This is why
I got advantage on the basis of caste. Now
what is Al Qader?
I had decided that whenever Allah gave me a
chance, I did two things,
Rahmatullah, I
set up my children from Sirte Nabis schools, get them
researched,  Character building has started,
our Akhlaq is completely finished, let
us raise it in continuation of the Seerat of our Prophet
and secondly, I thought of this university as
Rahmatullahi mine and this other university was
Al Qader University in which we
tried to do research on Seerat-e-Nabi.
I engaged international scholars
and then technology should also be taught
to the children. This meant that they should
teach modern technology like artificial intelligence
as well as their leadership development
[music]. He meant that it was
his hobby that if this
prophet is spread widely then it should be taught.  Trustee has been kept, it is
written in the deed that the name of the trustee
is the salary, Nak can get the money,
nor does he have anything in the property, he has
no connection with the trustee only because of '
ji', the trust was formed, the masala was Shaukat, neither
I nor Shaukat, we are  If 75% of the poor were to be the mufti
lodge of cancer, then it should not be that they
do it i.e. the
trust which was done by the policy
number of the university
and was done by Naan because Al Kader is being
run by a professional, all the children are mostly
getting it.  Also Alka, if I am
studying, everyone is getting it for free and
secondly, I told you that I did it for the purpose, it
benefited me, so why not, it
benefited you politically, yes, I have understood from Rahal Kadar
that
I am only for you.  Just wanted to tell that so much
propaganda is going on, after making people know, he made
me sit on the new platform for two and a half hours and kept
asking again and again that you have got a
big benefit from this and you have made Malik Riaz the
biggest builder of Pakistan.
He is Malik Riaz and Malik Raj. What was my
interest? What was my
interest? If I call the
Prime Minister an
international scholar, he has the equipment that reduces it the fastest. No one reduces it as fast as Malik Riaz's construction.  I am
being investigated and whatever they found in me was
amazing, I was so changed that they
gave me an inquiry
and on the 28th I will investigate with an inquiry
and
every day I pick me up from there, a ranger will go and present
me to you as per my wish.  The
way he
loved me was that day of picking me up I was
sitting to pick up the bail because we came to
know from the newspapers on
30th June and on 30th April then we came to know
that he investigated the
case. My lawyer wrote to the Islamabad High Court, what a joke this is.
This day, I was going to Islamabad High
Court ISP, in the court, when
they took the newspaper out from there and
caught it, when I reached Jai, the first
time they showed me the inquiry report,
then this was the drama sir.  Said, I will
tell you all that
no one should tolerate this
and many of my people are going through a lot of difficulties,
but I want to tell the rest that
this kind of slavery of putting them in my life
is better than accepting this kind of slavery.
Why has Allah given such a big status to freedom? When a
person fights for his freedom, Allah
calls him a Shahid and when he dies, he is called a Shahid and what is
saved is called a
Ghazi. Why does Shahid have the highest status after the Prophets? He
created me.  Those who are enslaving us,
when I am
leaving you in the style of Dhaba's throat and curry's grip,
and who bows her head in front of oppression,
as long as there is blood inside her, she will stand and
fight till the last ball.  You are Captain, there is
no question of who
will do this.